hi guys it's silver at again and I know
that I promised that this would be a
uncut series and it's still going to be
because I'm still going to do boring
stuff this episode should I really say
that I don't think so
but yeah that's it but as you can see or
may see I've placed some extra rocks
over here now this is something that I
actually had to cut out because I don't
know if I taught this in this tutorial
series yet but my webber's launch box
just keeps crushing every goddamn time
and I don't know why it does that it
never used to do that and for some
reason it doesn't do that on many other
people species but for me it has just
been crushing for some random reasons as
of lately and I've actually tried
re-downloading it and reinstalling it
but it just keeps doing that so the only
way that I can actually use it right now
is to open up the game play some rocks
are [ __ ] save then at some point it
crashes and I need to reopen it and
place a couple of other rocks and I
don't quite want to do that in a video
so that's why I kind of did that
off-screen so I'm sorry about that but
let's continue with some of the boring
stuff that I still needed to do because
as much as I still want to do the
foliage and there's still some path work
stuff that's left unfinished and even
though this is kind of it
path work just takes a lot of time
there's no real way to get around this
but I promise that this would be an
uncut series or at least as uncut as I
could do it with all the rock work
problems and all that so I'm going to
also feature this in my videos and let's
see all of this looks pretty good I just
need to add a small border and I'll call
it a day I'm not really going to work
too much on this now however I do kind
of want to make this straight so I'm
just gonna do that and hmm it's gonna
make it connect like that now that
should be good enough really
although Lottie I don't know how I'm
really going to finish this little
Bulevar thing I might just add a little
war using the same
okay it should work fine I really don't
know what I need to say about this this
is just kind of a situational thing it's
not really anything that you normally
want to do also if I could give a tip is
to usually keep your abou device
straight or at least as straight as
possible because many sets don't have
all of the weed curbing pieces it's a
lot easier and it often looks better as
well as you if you're Bulevar is as
straight as you can sometimes you have a
small bend in it though like it goes
diagonal and then it goes straight again
I guess that's okay though okay okay
yeah and you may see that I have many
extra custom scenery sets and this also
surprised me what I didn't really
surprise me but it caught me off guard
because I am sort of doing some
collaboration stuff and for recording a
video
I had to install all of the custom
scenery that those guys used and that
was actually a lot so and I don't have a
lot so I need to get used to all of this
so I'm sorry if I can't really find my
way in all of this okay so I found CTR
path that's very nice and let's see nice
little straight piece this is all just a
simple old stuff that I've talked about
earlier just make sure that the pieces
connect because you don't want you
and nothing that goes too far I think it
has a two tile curve that should work
out very nice and then I just need a
half piece and another four point oh
wait no actually two half pieces there
we go
very nice and now to finish this little
sidewalk thing then it my hat is moving
in rank okay I need this side yeah I
don't know if I really want to just make
it like this because obviously this is
not going to connect so it might be a
smarter move to just remove this and
connect it to this little piece over
there let's just try that I don't think
shin okay so I didn't have to remove
that piece I don't know why I did that
it just seemed logical in my mind I
guess this works I'm not sure about the
path covers though but I'm pretty
positive that it should work out okay so
a 2 x 2 over here okay no there we go
it's it's all screwed over hmm well in
that case I actually don't know what to
do with that that's not very good and
there is no other curving piece like
this so I don't think there's another
option to do this but that means that
we'll have to do this in a very
different way this is this is obviously
not something that you're going to
encounter too often this is probably
even though this is actually the first
time that I've had this problem but I do
want everything to look good and you
don't want things to stick out of your
paths you don't want borders not
matching up with the paths and stuff
like that so it's always at least I find
it better to just do some random stuff
that you wouldn't do like adding this
little curve even though
it looks a bit awkward it looks less
awkward than a curb going through
another curb and the sidewalks sticking
out of the curb and stuff like that
that's definitely a no-go
that's probably even worse in any
scenario than having a weird shape so
weird shapes over well
curbs that stick out any day okay so
let's just add this and another piece
and it seems like we need a quarter half
piece and then when we're nearly done
okay so now what else do we need well a
couple of lanterns on the other side so
it's time for station jim's gardening
too it seems
yeah okay let me find that ah there we
go
and that one light that I need is this
one now of course make sure that the
colors are the same at least if you have
OCD like me you'd want to do that okay
which color is it okay it's the middle
one and now choose an interval and I
don't know why you kind of do want to
have the same interval between now light
and the lampposts I can't really say
what kind of interval should be it also
depends on the lamps but I'd say that
usually just going for what you feel
like it's good yeah so this is like four
and a half although that doesn't quite
work at the end or does it actually does
oh very nice okay so that wait no it
doesn't match with the rest of the pike
never mind about that just gonna move
this you can move everyone one tile and
then we're good to go
beautiful now of course I kind of want
to play some benches on this side as
well might as well I'm a bench freak so
yeah I just can't resist urge
I'm just kind of like that don't want to
have them in the middle of your path but
to it weird
the
oh this is pretty safe hmm still gonna
place it further away from it and no one
over there I'd say one over here perhaps
I kind of like I don't know when it
comes to placing benches there's no real
technique behind it really it's just
place them wherever you feel like place
it's easy to overplay it's them
I'm already over placing them here holy
[ __ ] that's way too many benches this is
already too many honestly I'm gonna keep
them because I'm a bench freak but
honestly realistically speaking it's too
many benches now of course we need some
fences to finish this off and very
important to take the same colors top
one seems to be this color and no
actually that's that one and then this
should be that blue color oh it's a is
it yeah it's a it's not blue is it it's
green or not it's this shade of green
okay yeah got it
nice okay so we're just going to place
those and the curve is gonna start over
here and once again you can just overlap
these fences there's no real problem in
that it's a couple more polys so if you
want to be well careful with the police
if you have a bad computer I would not
recommend doing it but really it just
saved some cases so if you're lazy you
can do that you won't get any clipping
like you get with many fences and this
one seems to be from branches set so
we're gonna have to get that branches
wooden fences beautiful and it has posts
as well so that's really good and these
posts seem to be from station gyms
fencing and we still had that opened so
that's very nice little brown thing on
top
okay nice there we go so that little
area is finished it's not too not too
special however I do feel like it needs
some some nice little planters action
yeah definitely question is where and
how how would I go about doing that
okay I don't really know what to do with
this little area but I do know that I
went to get some planters and now as
usual I would recommend placing the
trees first and then the planters it's
not really necessary to do this these
days but I haven't really explained this
too much when I was doing the planters
over here but there are basically two
advantages to doing this one would be
that many tree sets don't have all of
the placing all of the placements that
many planters have so it's very handy
handy to place the trees first and then
see which kind of planters you can use
instead of placing the planters first
and then realizing that there's no tree
to actually put in them because of the
placements and a second advantage to it
would be the fact that you can kind of
see the way it looks before you start
placing the planters because of course
the trees have a much larger impact on
the general surroundings and the
planters they're standing in okay so
does this look okay I don't think so
well we are in a somewhat subtropical
Florida ish climate so a couple of palm
trees wouldn't hurt right I might try
some palm trees actually that pretty
cool not see so we're just going to open
spices palms again these are arguably
the best palms in the game obviously
this is just my opinion but in terms of
detail and everything they're probably
the best ones oh god I don't want to
have any palm tree in front of a bench
but I don't know
oh wait we need that one over there
there we go hmm okay I have a better
idea to place all of them on this side
like that and some of them are too large
obviously this is an advantage to the
set I like this the fact that it has the
random size and everything simply
because you get loads of different sizes
and forms and shapes of palm trees and
trees in general with spices sets and
you don't have that with station gym set
I I don't think I don't know if this is
really a good idea but you might have
noticed it and this is actually great
when building forests because if you try
to place the same tree all over the
place you're not going to get the same
tree in the same angle with us and with
the same size and all that but you will
get that with many of station gems trees
so that's actually one reason why I
sometimes choose old Spice's trees over
station Jim's trees even though they are
not that detail okay so this looks
pretty good so it's time for some
planters and as always I'm just going to
go with my favorite planters honestly
you can choose whichever planter you
like though I would recommend to a well
it doesn't really matter for one project
but I I would kind of recommend you just
changing it change it up every once in a
while I don't know why but I just feel
I'm just kind of afraid that if I keep
doing the same time in the same thing
everywhere every time it's gonna be a
sort of routine however it go really
well with the palm trees so might as
well and this palm tree is kind of no
wait this I'll god I removed
I removed the wrong trees that was very
stupid and why did I put that plant over
there he didn't wanna miss click okay
two more palm trees and then I'm gonna
see if there's anything else that I
still need to do before I start heading
into the general foliage and that's not
gonna take too much it's not going to
take too long really just a couple of
episodes okay so that looks really cool
it
it W palm trees somewhere over here
probably not no though I could
potentially place some over here I'm
afraid that it might ruin the view of
the queue yeah it's kind of weird now I
wouldn't do that might play some palm
trees on the other side though but it's
that's not gonna have too much of an
impact on anything it's just gonna be
palm trees for the sake of palm trees I
don't know if that's a good idea because
you don't want to spam palm trees never
ever overuse palm trees palm trees are
very heavy on the maintenance costs and
time and all that they need to be
watered all the time or something like
that basically that's why you rarely see
any palm trees sometimes you have like
rich hotels and [ __ ] have the palm trees
outside but they're very hard to
maintain so usually don't spam them even
in our jungle issue climate jungles
aren't filled with just palm trees
they're much more well complicated than
that
so making palm tree forests is always a
no-go that's something to remember I'd
say I see many people doing it but it's
not realistic in any case even if you're
building a tropical coaster but yeah
that's pretty much it I'm just kind of
looking around and seeing if there's
anything that I still need to fix up I
just look at that the the textures for
the path because they're not really
great everywhere speaking of textures I
probably can't do foliage in the next
episode simply because the textures need
to be done as well they're the grand
textures they're not very great
everywhere yet okay now I do want to
have a little dark border over here I
don't know if I can really do that over
here but just gonna give it give it a
try oh this actually works nice
okay get that nice little nice little
edge that I've talked about earlier and
of course I might always add a little
hedge or other shrubbery over there you
don't really have to worry about those
textures yet really if there's anything
that looks kind of ugly you don't really
have to worry it worry about it in the
first place because you can generally
cover things up and I know this might
seem like a very lazy and stupid
approach to things but I think that many
people actually do that and as long as
nobody note knows it it's not a problem
I guess
mm-hmm but yeah this looks pretty cool I
think that everything except for that
for the foliage and some of the ground
textures is done right now yeah that's
really awesome so that's it for this
episode very small episode just rounding
up the final things finally and we're
finally able to move on to the last
couple of things before this coaster is
finished so yeah I'm gonna do that in
the next episode so see you then